djillali annane bonjour merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors on lisait
une consultation très manuelle macro et
des membres du gouvernement doit avoir
lieu en cette semaine sur la question
n'a pas sanitaires pour le médecin que
vous êtes
est-ce que c'est effectivement un bon
outil contre pour lutter contre la
propagation du virus
je crois qu'il faut distinguer impasse
qui servirait à voyager au delà des
frontières voire delà des frontières de
l'espace de schengen d'un instrument qui
y seraient pour la réguler la mobilité
des personnes à l'intérieur même du pays
pour aller ou pas accéder à certaines
activités culturelles ou sociales
dans le deuxième cas cela me semble à la
fois prématurée et probablement peu
réaliste dans le premier cas c'est à
dire pour voyager soit pour du tourisme
soit pour des voyages d'affaires
je crois qu'il est effectivement
important que l'europe notamment au sein
de l'espace de schengen
celui ce d'un outil qui lui permettent
de réguler la circulation des personnes
venant de l'extérieur de l'espace de
schengen et souhaitant rentrer à
l'intérieur de l'espace schengen alors à
propos de ce pass voyez ce que précisait
le secrétaire d'état aux affaires
européennes dimanche dernier clément
bonne alors on l'a pas on va pas
l'entendre mais voilà il précisait ce
qu'on pouvait éventuellement avoir dans
spa sanitaires pour vous ça serait quoi
alors du coup ça serait voir si la
personne a été vaccinée voir si elle a
été testés négatifs qu'est ce qu'on
pourrait trouver pas aujourd'hui il
faudrait il faudrait impérativement
retrouver un résultat de test pcr parce
que c'est quand même aujourd'hui
l'élément le plus rigoureux pour
prévenir la contamination et la
propagation du virus
c'est la seule façon de savoir qu'une
personne n'est pas contagieuse le vaccin
pour l'instant encore une fois on ne
connaît pas la durée de protection
apportée par le vaccin c'est un facteur
limitant aux passeports vaccinale
deuxièmement tous les patients tout et
personne pardon qui sont vaccinées ne
vont pas avoir le même
niveau de protection les unes par
rapport aux autres et enfin
troisièmement à ce jour tout le monde
loin de là n'a pas encore eu accès à la
vaccination donc on créerait quand même
une grande inégalité entre les personnes
si on introduisait comme élément
incontournable le vaccin dans ce
passeport dans ce pass sanitaires
aujourd'hui en france et 5%
la population qui est vaccinée est ce
que le débat finalement il n'est pas
prématuré
oui bien sûr en tout cas le débat est
si l'on souhaite y introduire la
vaccination parce que très clairement la
france a pris du retard est loin d'avoir
rattrapé son retard
on espère que elle va réussir à le
rattraper avant l'été mais rien n'est
moins certain
donc dès lors on ne peut pas fonder une
stratégie sur la vaccination
lorsqu'il existe une telle incertitude
sur la capacité que l'on aura à à
proposer la vaccination à une majorité
d'adultes en france d'ici la fin de
l'été
en tout cas au milieu de lagardère en
souvient il n'était absolument pas
question de mettre en place ce type de
passeport précisément vaccinale qu'est
ce qui fait que d'un point de vue
médical et bien les choses aient évolué
sur cette question d'abord le fait que
l'on a un accès malgré tout en échelle
mondiale plus facile à la vaccination
on a maintenant près d'une dizaine de
vaccins au niveau international qui sont
on le sait efficace donc c'est très
différent de la situation de leur milieu
ou de la fin de l'année dernière cette
information elle est importante à
prendre en compte et c'est ça qui du
coup amène à discuter ou à travailler
sur les modalités pour rétablir une
circulation des personnes notamment au
travers des frontières tout en assurant
à contrôler permanente sur l'épidémie et
en évitant qu'il y ait une reprise
épidémique au niveau planétaire
alors pour certains la mise en place
d'un passeport sanitaires et bien ça
rime avec vaccination obligatoire est-ce
que c'est l'effective mans la logique
qui va suivre selon vous oui enfin c'est
très clairement c'est le pass noir
vaccinale reviendrait d'une certaine
façon à rendre la vaccination
obligatoire si on utiliser cet outil
pour vous permettre d'aller au cinéma au
restaurant au bar donc là très
clairement ça serait rendre la
vaccination obligatoire et ça je crois
que c'est donc contraire à ce que le
président de la république lui même a
souhaité à quelques mois j'ai justement
est ce que en tant que médecin il ya des
questions éthiques qui se pose avec la
mise en place d'un tel passeport
ben oui la première dès qu'elles soient
tic encore une fois c'est
l'accessibilité à la vaccination pour
tous dans les mêmes délais de la même
façon aujourd'hui on n'a pas encore cet
objectif
donc on créerait une inégalité entre les
personnes en parlent pastor vaccinale
deuxièmement ça pose la question de la
protection des données des personnes
nous c'est qu'aujourd'hui on y est tous
très attachés et en particulier
lorsqu'il s'agit de données sanitaires
comme celle ci est aussi à une question
qui se pose est ce que à quoi ça
servirait un passeport sanitaire dans le
sens où aujourd'hui et bien finalement
le vaccin il ne protège pas contre une
contamination
c'est cela non je crois qu'aujourd'hui
on des arguments maintenant solide
notamment grâce à l'expérience nationale
en israël pour ce dire qu'effectivement
la vaccination va également réduire le
nombre de contaminations à car personnel
et donc réduire considérablement la
propagation du virus
pour cette information là où la
vaccination contre la copie de 19
finalement n'est pas différente de la
vaccination contre d'autres maladies
infectieuses
elle protège également de la
transmission du virus d'une personne à
l'autre et donc permet de lutter contre
la propagation du virus
il ya aussi la multiplication des
variants on en voit de plus en plus
c'est ce que ça pourrait rendre
rapidement
inefficace l'idée d'un passeport
sanitaires c'est une vraie inquiétude
on le voit d'ailleurs ans en
grande-bretagne dans décosse et en
angleterre où commencent à apparaître
des cas rapportés de mutants brésil gars
dont on sait qu'il est malheureusement
très à risque de résister à la
vaccination
et s'il donnait à s'installer
durablement et sur le sol britannique
il risquerait de m malheureusement en
échec la campagne vaccinale britannique
donc on voit bien que oui les vaccins
les mutants pardon représente une menace
importante pour mettre fin à l'épidémie
et donc il est vraiment fondamental de
s'opposer d'empêcher coûte que coûte
leur propagation et leur installation en
europe en particulier
il paraîtrait un vous parler de la
grande bretagne que la grande-bretagne
et les etats-unis vont atteindre leur
immunité collective d'ici la fin de
l'année c'est quelque chose de possible
bien sûr c'est toujours quelque chose de
possible
est-ce que c'est certain sûrement pas
parce qu'encore une fois il persiste une
inconnue importante dans cette équation
qui est la durée de la protection
vaccinale
donc on ne connaît pas aujourd'hui avec
certitude combien de temps les personnes
sont protéger d'une contamination d'une
infection lorsqu'ils ont été vaccinées
est ce que ces trois mois ce que ces six
mois est-ce que c'est un an
il n'y a que le temps qui nous permettra
de répondre à cette question alors en
attendant la mise en place d'un éventuel
passeport sanitaire aujourd'hui on a des
mesures qui sont bien en place
on pense notamment au couvre-feu jérôme
l'affirmé il a parlé d'une mesure qui a
prouvé son efficacité
jérôme salomon pardon est ce que c'est
vraiment le cas oui ces mesures de
couvre-feu ont une efficacité
est ce qu'elles sont efficientes
autrement dit est-ce qu'elles ont une
efficacité satisfaisant la réponse
allait non allez encore une fois de
façon très objectif qu'a-t-on gagner
comme liberté supplémentaire en france
depuis trois mois
aucune au contraire on en a perdu deux
nouvelles est ce que l'on a réussi à
infléchir la courbe des contaminations
et a ramené le nombre de contestations
en dessous d'eux
la réponse est là encore non donc on
voit bien que les mesures restrictives
que l'on subit depuis trois mois
notamment le couvre-feu est dorénavant
dans beaucoup de territoires
le confinement le week end ce sont des
mesures très contraignantes qui ont une
certaine efficacité mais qui ne sont pas
suffisamment efficaces pour mettre fin à
la deuxième vague qui continue de
frapper la france donc une non ces
mesures restent insuffisantes elles
n'ont qu'une efficacité partielle et moi
je trouve très optimiste les propos du
président ado milk dont il estime que
dans quatre à six semaines
on en aura fini et qu'on pourra
retrouver de liberté je n'y crois pas
une seule seconde
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup el djillali
annane d'avoir répondu à nos questions
dans la matinale de rtl franc jeu en
appel vous êtes un chef du service de
réanimation à l'hôpital raymond-poincaré
de garches